we've talked about what makes an
uncompressed two-dimensional image in
memory and now we're going to try and
take that step further to three
dimensions or indeed more dimensions if
that's your thing for a computer
scientist the difference between
two-dimensional data and three
dimensional data is really neither here
nor there we just have more data on the
end that we use to represent us at our
next dimension in an image it's much the
same thing so where we had our header
before and we have pixel 1 and then
pixel 2 depending on the size of image
these pixels will go through the rows of
our first image and then we'll start
straight on with the rows of our next
image ok so if I image is let's say 2 by
2 by 2 like this and we sometimes refer
to these as voxels volumetric pixels so
this will be pixel 1 here in this box
this will be pixel 2 3 & 4 so after our
padding we might have pixel 3 here and
pixel 4 here and then we crack straight
on with pixel 5 6 7 but behind this cube
and 8 down here so we literally go
straight into 5 6 7 8 and it's just a
huge one-dimensional array just like
with our two-dimensional data and the
formula for calculating our position is
just an extension of the former we
talked about last time so we now have a
z-index this is our X this is our Y and
this is our Z going back like this this
is our stride the number of bytes per
row this is the number of bytes per
image and then our total file so now if
we call this let's say depth okay then
we can say that our pixel P anywhere in
our three-dimensional structure is equal
to Z times by Baudette plus y times by
the stride plus X and what we're
essentially doing here is with our Zed
we jump to the specific image in our
depth then we jump to a specific row and
then we jump to a specific pixel that we
want and then just like with normal
images that pixel may contain a red a
green a blue may be an alpha or it could
be grayscale the interesting thing about
3d images for me is that the depth
dimension could actually be something
other than depth so in a video it's time
each frame is a
actually moving forward and our depth is
essentially each frame one after another
in a big stack you could use the word
Vauxhall to represent a
three-dimensional pixel if you like I
don't tend to unless it represents some
kind of actual volume in a video
Professor primal did in the 3d CT data
we have a two-dimensional set of image
slices through a volume and together
they make a three-dimensional volume and
once we've sigmund today the route
portions we have voxels that are
essentially route and box of it not
route and we can distinct between the
two people will be familiar with voxel
based games like minecraft or lots of
other ones and they work in much the
same way in Minecraft you have space
which takes up voxels or you have matter
which could be soil or something else
and it still represented as a big volume
so for each X Y Zed location the the map
the level data file will hold whether
various soil at that location or empty
space or something else so I've got a
few examples that we can look at to see
if I get my laptop here so I've loaded
three different types of
three-dimensional image data using a
software package just to demonstrate
really that at a low level once they're
uncompressed them we're not considering
any kind of file format problems they're
really very similar so this particular
image I'm looking at now is a free
dimensional slice of a root section so
this is taken using a composer laser
scanning microscope a confocal laser
microscope but what that does is bounce
lasers into the root and when it come
out
it captures that color and works out
what's going on inside the tissue and
the nice thing about a laser microscope
is you can actually capture slices
through a route deep into the tissue
without actually having to cut it up a
bit like in the same way that the x-ray
CT works with x-rays so in this case
we've got an X Y Z three-dimensional
image whereas edit sod is our depth
through the loop so if I move this
slider here this is our x and y and then
this slider down here is our Zed and
we're stepping through the route and
moving downwards and you can see that
the route gets thinner as we approach
the end and then factor again and you
can see all the nuclei and the cell
walls to give you an idea of the scale
of this image this route is about 120
microns wide this is actually thinner
than a human hair you can barely see
them yourself which is why we're on this
really powerful microscope so this is
our image where our Z dimensions
representing depth this is a different
type of image taken using a
hyperspectral camera so hyperspectral
camera instead of measuring simply RG
and B it measures a lot more than that
in fact a thousand different wavelengths
for this particular camera and this is
all the way from 400 nanometers which is
sort of deep blow all the way up into
the infrared at a thousand nanometers in
this instance at a Z dimension that
we're looking at is wavelength at this
case showing us 400 nanometers so as we
go through here we'll see the different
colors and how the plant reflects
different patterns of light so if we
increase the wavelength now we can see
but the plant doesn't reflect much blue
but the flower does which is why we can
see the flowers nice and quietly and
then as we go further on we can see but
the plant suddenly starts reflecting and
that's where we're now at the green most
plants appear green because they absorb
blue and red views in photosynthesis and
reflect green so if we continue going up
through the wavelengths as we get to the
red we'll see a big drop-off in the
amount of reflectance and that's because
all that light's been absorbed but you
can see again that the flowers were
extremely bright and that is essentially
sort of a target for insects doing their
foraging a really fruitless because the
strawberries it's a straw we plot yes
there's no fruit on this it's too young
unfortunately we don't get to eat them
all so if you've seen the lab you
probably wouldn't want to eat the fruit
what we're looking at is how the help of
the plant affects for kind of light
wavelengths but it reflects so as we go
up into the infrared you can see the
plant becomes extremely bright and
that's because we're affecting a lot of
infrared light so this image in memory
it's very much like our depth stack
except but now we're representing our
our third dimension or something else in
this case wavelength finally this is
just a simple video some horses running
on a beach spoke Pleasant and in this
case our Z dimension is simply time or
number of frames so if we go through we
can see we can go out back and forth and
it works in exactly the same way as we
have a image data this is all in a huge
chunk of memory and when it needs to
render a certain image it will jump to
that position and read off those rows
what we've seen is that
three-dimensional images held in memory
wants of uncompressed and we're not
concerning ourselves and what format
they're in are very much like
two-dimensional images this list
features more data on the end so instead
of jumping just by rows and by pixels we
can also jump by image in the stack and
we'd go further back and then we can use
that to hold videos
or depth stacks 3d data like in the case
of our boots or hyperspectral data and
so we can we do anything we want with
with with this free dimensional data and
if you wanted to take it further we
could have let's say a series of
hyperspectral images taken over time and
then you've got four dimensional image
data and then the operations just become
increasingly long we've got a lot of
investment in 8-bit code how can we
exploit that investment whilst getting
into the 16-bit market and so what we
had sketched on the table was it was
effectively a dual processor system